despite Donald Trump signing that
executive order to try to move forward
on the Dakota access pipeline there's a
group of military veterans that is
saying it is not going to happen we are
going to be there to stop it and we
heard now from a number of
representatives from the group veterans
stand including Anthony Diggs who said
we are committed to the people of
Standing Rock we are committed to
non-violence and we will do everything
within our power to ensure that the
environment and human life are respected
that pipeline will not get completed not
on our watch of course many military
veterans who don't share this position
have been all over the internet saying
hey you know what veterans stand does
not stand for our views and that's
absolutely fine because you know what
you don't need every military veteran to
show up to actually prevent the pipeline
from going forward and digs at it that
they're hoping to raise enough money to
have funds for a really significant
boots on the ground presence the
Secretary of the army instructed the
Army Corps of Engineers to grant energy
transfer partners that's the
controversial company in which Donald
Trump we know at one point had a stake
we were told he no longer does but of
course no proof has been provided that
he has divested himself from that
organization in any case the US
Secretary of the army has told the US
Army Corps of Engineers grant the
easement to ETP so that they can get
going on the final piece of this
pipeline I really hope it doesn't happen
I am hugely supportive of whoever wants
to show up there and prevent this from
going forward we know that before when
the pipeline stalled the protests were a
part of why it stopped and it set up a
major PR challenge and veterans showing
up there every day is gonna create a PR
problem for the Trump administration and
I think at the time everyone knew that
it was a temporary win but yeah the
fight was far from over it's really
heartwarming to see veterans serve their
country overseas and then come back and
continue to do so here absent I think
they're also uniquely qualified to fight
against some of the tactics that the
police are using things like tear gas
interesting water cannons sound cannons
they're probably the best qualified I
didn't consider that police increasingly
militarized to get us protesters so then
the actual former mill
Terry shows up to do the protesting that
is an interesting thing the saddest
background is of course that the world
is laughing at us we've got India and
China very quickly becoming the leaders
on moving away from fossil fuels and
cutting emissions and cutting pollution
and alternative energy and we're trying
to save fossil fuel jobs with a science
a non science president who's reflecting
the non science beliefs through his
appointments it's embarrassing I mean it
went when I know that some rightists
trumpets trombones are emboldened when
they hear the rest of the world doesn't
like what we're doing they say well
we're gonna do it anyway and we don't
care what the rest of the world thinks
the reality is the rest of the world is
laughing because they realize how
misguided it is to try to be rescuing
coal for example in 2017 and we were on
the path to becoming the forerunner when
it comes to alternative energy I mean
the Obama administration say what you
want about them but they had they had us
on that path it seemed they could have
been more aggressive but I at least set
up a trajectory which 5 10 20 years out
with different milestones would have
made really really big progress and
ultimately they came against these
pipelines not only dakota access but
also keystone absolutely and i support
what these military veterans are doing
and i believe that we need to stop the
Dakota access pipeline as well as the
Keystone XL pipeline and we're gonna
keep you abreast of the situation that's
for sure